mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video ob er vor
ein paar tagen schon mal mit dem pew die
wort geredet
und heute ist es wieder an der zeit dass
wir ihn einfach fragen stehen
ihr seht ihr schon im juni bot
eingeblendet ich habe ich schon vorhin
bisschen mit ihm geschrieben wie es ihm
geht und meinte gut und dir das heißt
wir haben jetzt etwa wieder so ein
bisschen mit dem herum und ins gespräch
reinzukommen mir geht es ebenfalls gut
lieber keyboard das freut mich
was machst du gerade so alter da kommt
eine richtige unterhaltung gerade
zustande
ich spreche gerade mit dir also ich
meine was anderes mache ja gerade nicht
und sonst so ich gehe gleich was für
vieles deger warum schon wieder verliert
ist es macht keinen sinn es macht
einfach keinen sinn schon wie
[Musik]
warum mussten wir das so
ich gehe gleich in die uni lieber
polizei wie spät es ist es ist gerade 13
uhr 25 juli bord was machst du ich habe
dir gerade ca 400 mal gesagt dass ich
mit dir rede dass ich gleich in die uni
gehen habe ich doch gerade bereits
gesagt vom punkt punkt
nein hast du
und jetzt das
anderes thema punkte
youtube über bord ich gebe jetzt sterben
warum bio die bahn muss sterben reden
weil du das gesagt hast ich habe das
nicht sagt lieber bot du kannst es alles
ihn doch das hast du gesagt wo er
behauptet die ganze zeit ich hätte ihnen
was gesagt oder nicht gesagt aber was
ich bereits heute gemacht habe was ich
gerade tue dass er sterben soll bist du
dumm fragezeichen lieber beauty body ich
bin nicht dampf
mast youtube videos ist das richtig
lieber ab juli fort ja weil ich es
gesagt habe hast du zwar nicht aber ich
glaubte dass man einfach also kennst du
dich auch ein wenig mit der plattform
aus die kenne ich nicht
juli bot du lebst youtube videos hoch
und das ist dein verdienst und um sagt
wie du kennst dich nicht mit deinem
arbeitgeber aus
soll ich das jetzt glauben ich komme
direkt auf den punkt und zwar kennst du
konkreter also milch und erkenntnis
ja er
er kennt mich ja wir wissen dass du für
biblis bis ich bin crafter lieber für
die potters heißt du
[Musik]
wir können nicht beide konkreter sein
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
er meint wir sind beide kontrakte also
sind wir beide die gleiche person nicht
dass jetzt richtig verstanden habe auf
frick in kiew juni erst mal warum reden
wir englisch und zweitens warum willst
du mich töten
ich frage nur für beide die gleiche
person sind
[Musik]
ich fange jetzt mal von vorne an und
zwar kennst du den youtuber kong kräfte
darauf antwortet der keyboard dass er
erst mal noch überlegt und er überlegt
immer noch nein
wohin wohin kanntest du mich noch dicker
vorhin kanntest du congo after doch noch
lieber keyboard also ich verstehe das
nicht so ganz dass er mir die ganze zeit
sagt dass endlich kennen dann hätte mir
nicht okay aber wo treffen wir uns denn
du willst du dich irgendwo treffen
uniboard also ich verstehe das wg nicht
so ganz will ich doch gar nicht man
sieht es gerade sogar noch eingeblendet
du hast vorhin selber du bist
manchmal denke ich mir wenn ich wenn ich
mir angucke dass das einfach dass mein
leben wirklich keinen sinn macht
korn kraft dazu also welcher noch
konkreter lieber ab juli bot über den
haben vorhin schon geredet falls sich
auch daran erinnern welcher noch
academy
[Musik]
schon gefragt von crafter lieber
uniboard welcher ich will nicht schon
wieder aufstehen weglaufen weil ich
heute morgen im gym und das tut alles
weh aber am liebsten würdigkeit
aufstehen und weglaufen von crafter juli
bot ok welcher noch der youtube.com
crafter ich meine vielleicht hing war
dann eine vernünftige antwort wenn ich
das jetzt einfach mal abstieg ios habe
ich getan
wieder komplett von vorne an und zwar
kennst du pont crafter lieber privat ich
will es wirklich mal rausfinden also das
nicht wohin geschrieben ja jetzt
schreibst du wieder ja ok
guckst du seine videos lieber keyboard
also kommt wirklich darauf eine antwort
manchmal steigt meine videos
ist
komplett das ist ein life ball von mir
lieber die bosse kennst du kollege der
boss ja ich kenne kollege welches ist
dein lieblingslied von ihm ja so gut
kenne ich den jetzt auch nicht ich
glaube früher der mann liegt gemacht das
heißt adrenalin oder so aber das braucht
eben ganz alten das ist kein song von
rammstein
[Musik]
er fragt mich nach kollegah frage mich
was das lieblingslied von ihm ist und
ich sagen lied von ihm und er sagt das
ist nicht von rammstein natürlich ist
nicht von rammsteins von kollegah ist
youtube website blendet das einfach
immer total geschockt
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
was getan hat las bahn vettel liegt da
hier findet ihr in smiley eingeblendet
werden da drauf klick könnte meinen
kanal abonnieren es ist kostenlos vier
verpasst keine videos mehr und hier
findet ihr ein anderes video
eingeblendet also klickt ihr einfach mal
drauf ich meine was macht ihr jetzt
sonst einfach mal drauf klicken
[Musik]